in January of 2023 Microsoft announced
that they would be investing $10 billion
into open aai the parent company of chat
GPT it's been over an year since that
day and open aai is now reporting that
they've only received a fraction of the
promised $10 billion this isn't to say
that Microsoft won't follow through with
their full investment after all $10
billion is just a drop in the bucket for
a $2.5 trillion giant like Microsoft but
it's also here that Microsoft isn't
exactly jumping up and down to pour more
funding into open AI in fact from the
very beginning Microsoft structured the
investment in tranches that would need
to be unlocked over a long period of
time and reading between the lines it
seems that tensions between open Ai and
Microsoft are more than just Financial
in November for example Microsoft was
forced to take a nonvoting position on
the open AI board despite owning 49% of
the company and and with the whole Sam
Alman Fiasco Microsoft may even have a
legitimate reason to completely back out
of the deal and that's just the most
notable AI drama it turns out that these
sort of fallouts are happening across
the board throughout the AI world as
VC's pullback on funding AI projects
with ridiculous valuations I mean just
think about this open AI was looking to
raise out a valuation of $90 billion and
the company barely pulls in $1 billion
in Revenue per year not to mention Sam
Alman himself has admitted that open AI
will need a 100 billion not in valuation
but in just funding to fully developed
generative intelligence and all of this
has been during a time in which chat GPT
has been slowly bleeding users month
after month none of this is to say that
AI is not the future because it
obviously is but it does seem like the
AI industry very much got ahead of
itself and VCS are starting to pull the
plug just recently for example a $4
billion AI Health startup named Olive
went under and Olive is simply one of a
growing list of unicorns turned to
zombies so here's the rise and fall of
the AI hype and what's next for the AI
[Music]
industry all burgeoning Industries go
through boom and bus Cycles that's just
how new Innovations and the tech is
created you have these massive bursts of
enthusiasm and excitement followed by a
harsh reality check before true
mainstream adoption begins that's
exactly what happened with all of the
dot companies in the early 2000s after
years of unlimited funding the vast
majority of dotom companies ended up
going under never to be heard of again
it was only after this cleansing that
internet companies like Amazon Google
and Facebook were really able to cement
themselves for the long term in most
Industries this sort of cycle takes
maybe 20 to 30 years but the same cannot
be said about the AI industry in fact AI
has been repeating the cycle over and
over again since the 1950s which brings
us back to the father of modern
Computing Alan Turing in 1950 Turing
would publish a landmark research paper
called Computing machinery and
intelligence in the paper he explores
the idea of whether computers can think
for which he offers a very simple answer
if a computer is able to engage in a
conversation with a human without the
human noticing that they're talking to a
computer then the machine can indeed
think he dubbed this test the imitation
game and this is what would eventually
become the famous touring test inspired
by these ideas hundreds of scientists
would begin working on their own AI
projects hoping to pass the touring test
this included more simple applications
like a Checkers bought in
1952 but it also included generative AI
in fact generative AI itself is by no
means a new invention as far back as the
1960s we've seen scientists grapple with
the concept of language models and
chatbots the Elisa chatbot for example
attempted to simulate the work of a
psychotherapist way back in 1961
scientists were even working on the
groundwork for self-driving vehicles in
the 1970s for example the Stanford cart
was able to navigate itself to a room
filled with obstacles it seemed like AI
was truly the next big thing but but do
you know what happened after these
breakthroughs the first AI winter
funding for AI startups was wiped out as
investors realized that it was a lot
more profitable to invest in chip and
computer companies with strong Revenue
potential as opposed to these
theoretical projects and that's exactly
what they did but after they made a crap
ton of money with companies like sun
Microsystems Intel Microsoft Sony and
Panasonic they would come back to the
speculation table Japan for example
would commit $850 million to what they
would call the fifth generation computer
project and IBM would begin work on a
Next Generation AI called the deep blue
the goal was to create a chest spot that
was better than the world had ever seen
this was by no means an easy task but in
1997 IBM would do it deep blue would
decisively beat the Chess World Champion
at the time Gary casprov once again it
seemed like AI was truly the next big
thing Not only was AI able to outsmart
an average Joe but a world champion this
was definitive proof that AI could do
great things but after that we would
enter yet another AI winter with
investors losing money hand over fist
during the dotom bust the last thing
they wanted to do was speculate on AI
projects with no Revenue potential that
was until they got rich again thanks to
web companies like Google Facebook
Amazon Uber Airbnb and so on bringing us
into the current cycle as you can see
for 70 years now ai has consistently
been this sort of elusive next big thing
that's almost within grasp but not quite
so will this time be any different well
at some point it does have to be
different that's kind of how AI
eventually becomes mainstream but
judging by history there's no guarantee
that this cycle is the cycle that's what
people have been thinking for the past
70 years only to be proven wrong over
and over again which brings us into the
question of
[Music]
why one of the biggest themes
surrounding each and every one of these
AI Winters is funding the reality is
that AI is an extremely expensive game
and it's only getting more and more
expensive each Cycle open AI for example
is having to pay $1 million per year to
get access to the right Engineers not to
mention the m massive data centers and
loads of gpus they need to make the
entire operation possible this is why
Sam Alman thinks they need a hundred
billion but all of that only tells half
the story because AI is a double-edged
sword not only does AI take a stupid
amount of money to bring to Market but
it usually has very little Revenue
potential at least in its original state
it often has to be evolved substantially
before being able to generate serious
Revenue as such investors are only
willing to take this Gamble when times
are good when their other Investments
are doing well when the tech industry as
a whole is booming and when they don't
know exactly where to invest their money
this is exactly what was happening
throughout the early 2020s investors had
hit it big with web companies and
unicorns and with 0% interest rates they
simply did not know where to put all
these profits so they put it into AI but
when the music stops playing as was the
case in the 1970s the early 2000s and
right now they're quick to cut losses
and move back to safety but even putting
the whole financing of AI aside it seems
that the industry is always stopped by
consistent internal factors themselves
for example limited computing power even
in the modern day where we have enough
computing power for basically any task
imaginable somehow we don't have enough
computing power for AI and the main
reason for this is that our needs are
also constantly evolving before we were
just trying to create AIS that could
hold conversation or excel at a board
game today we're trying to create AIS
that can not only hold conversation but
scour the entire web to answer our
questions similarly we're no longer
trying to create cars that can navigate
a room within 5 hours but cars that can
navigate any road live our demands of AI
are rising exponentially and as such the
resources needed to make these projects
a reality are also Rising exponentially
but even regardless of how many
resources we have it's usually only a
matter of time until we run into more ex
Paradox which describes the odd
disparity between human and computer
intelligence it turns out that doing
things that are super hard for humans
like Mass data analysis and calculations
are super easy for
computers however doing things that are
natural for humans like sensing depth
fine motor skills and innately
leveraging feedback control systems are
nearly impossible and if all those
challenges were not hard enough to
overcome themselves well we have yet to
discuss the biggest challenge which is
the rise of AI
phonies with any hot Trend it's only a
matter of time until the opportunists
step into the scene in crypto for
example for every Bitcoin and ethereum
there's hundreds of trash coins R pulls
nft projects and straight up scams it's
the same thing with the AI space just in
a more sophisticated manner for every
open AI or Tesla FSD type effort you've
got dozens of garbage startups most of
them have nothing to do with AI
whatsoever or they barely leverage AI
but they'll put it all over their
marketing and brand themselves as an AI
company in reality they're just a
construction or consulting firm but all
of a sudden they're an AI based
construction firm or an AI based
consulting firm from an outside
perspective the are obviously trash
companies that are overstating their use
of AI but for desperate VCS who missed
out on investing in open AI This truly
seems like the future sure they might
have missed out on bringing AI to search
or cars but they can still be the ones
to bring it to the Sewer industry or the
energy industry even though the
application is far more limited
fortunately this BS does not go on
forever but the fall of these zombie
companies is by no means graceful
usually what happens is investors pull
back on all kinds of AI investing and
only the good companies end up Surviving
the funding cut which is exactly what's
happening right now global VC funding
has plummeted from $170 billion in the
4th quarter of 2021 to 70 billion in the
third quarter of
2023 AI was one of the few sectors that
was holding up through this funding
collapse but we're starting to see
cracks within the AI world as well in Q3
of 2023 for example the number of aivc
deals shrunk by
27% technically the total value of these
deals increased by 39% to $6.1 billion
but 4 billion of that was just due to
one investment from Amazon and you could
say the same thing about all of 2023
actually the main reason the AI industry
held up as well as it did was simply due
to a handful of massive deals from
companies like Microsoft Nvidia Google
Salesforce and and Amazon when we take
these Flagship deals out of the picture
though the outlook for the rest of the
AI industry becomes quite Bleak and that
brings us into the question of what
happens next well most likely another AI
winter filled with bankruptcies the
flagship companies like open AI will
most likely survive but you probably
won't hear nearly as much about them on
the news as they enter a new phase of
research and development away from the
public light that isn't to say that this
cycle was useless though another
intrinsically cyclical sector is the
chip industry they have booms and busts
basically every decade or even multiple
times per decade but just because the
industry is volatile doesn't mean that
they're not making forward progress
chips today are not even comparable to
chips from the 1950s and it's the same
thing with AI historically it's simply
been a highly volatile industry and
we're currently going from a high to a
low but eventually the industry will see
the other side once again do you think
AI is overhyped comment that down below
another industry that's going through a
massive reality check is Big Tech check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Harry and I'll see you guys on
the next
one